[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
trocken sind heute habe ich ein ganz
besonderes video für euch und für viele
die jetzt schon sagen was ist das für
eine tolle neuen schritte dazu komme ich
später das zweite ich euch am ende des
videos noch erzählen
jetzt komme ich aber mal zu meinem
eigentlichen thema und zwar steht
weihnachten jetzt kurz vor der tür und
wie viele von euch wahrscheinlich auch
schon die erfahrung gemacht haben wenig
ins einkaufen geht bei uns zum globus da
ich echt die hölle los alle gegner noch
einkaufen und geschenke besorgen
und ich habe mir gedacht was könnte ich
dieses jahr zu weihnachten schenken ich
bin ja schon herzlich und so ein do it
yourself typ und deswegen schenke ich
ganz gerne sachen die von herzen kommen
und selbst gemacht sind weil ich finde
das beste und schönste was man den
menschen schenken kann ist die zeit die
man eben aufbringt und deswegen finde
ich gerade selbst gemachte geschenke
schön weil ich denke dass ihr diesen
menschen gegenüber dann wirklich
wertschätzung und ich habe mir überlegt
was wäre denn ein gutes last minute
geschenk sind nur noch wenige tage und
habe mir deswegen überlegt euch eine
idee zu zeigen und zwar kam ich auch auf
die idee wollen die liebe nicole von
nicoles zuckerwerk mir ein päckchen
geschickt hat sie hat mir hier plätzchen
geschickt und zwei milliarden und zwar
sind die so süß und eigentlich auch so
ein bisschen linde bastelei naja diese
gläser so schön verzieren kann und das
eine ist übrigens eine faktisch espresso
klick und türe und das andere ist eine
bratapfel konfitüren mit rosinen und
hier haben wir rasen muss nur die augen
und frauen aus
als vielen dank nochmal nicole für dein
geschenk das hat nicht wirklich sehr
gefreut und einem brief hat mich zu
tränen gerührt wenn ihr wissen wollt die
ganze konzept da geht es natürlich bei
nicole auch auf der seite und die kunst
zuckerberg heißt die bei facebook könnt
ihr sie finden dann würde ich mich
freuen wir da mal vorbeischaut das ist
nämlich eine ganz ganz liebe jetzt komme
ich zu meinem video und zwar habe ich
hier so eine süße kleine geschenkidee
das ist nämlich eine backmischung aus
dem glas und die wird da rein
geschichtet also alle trockenen zutaten
und das ist jetzt beispielsweise eine
backmischung für brownies und der
empfänger hast du das bild geschenkt
bekommt muss dann nur noch 2 93 gramm
butter hinzufügen alles verrühren und in
form geben und fertig und ich finde es
jetzt so verpackt ganz hübsch aus das
macht man einfach in so einem kleinen
weckglas weckglas sagt euch
wahrscheinlich allen was das ist ja hier
diese einmachglas marke die
wahrscheinlich auch eure oben kennt weil
sie damit die marmelade eingekocht und
ich finde das super six geschenkidee und
man kann natürlich das glasdach auch
weiter verwenden wobei diese ganz
praktisch wenn man kann darin sogar
kuchen backen aber eben nicht dass brown
ihr rezept und da zeigt sich jetzt
einfach mal wie man das macht das rezept
natürlich für die brownies und ich finde
sich einfach ein schönes geschenk ist
kostengünstig und ich habe jetzt 45
gläser etwa neun euro gezahlt und die
ganzen trockenen zutaten das kostet ja
auch was nix also das ist eine schöne
idee die er schnell machen könnt eben
gerade noch in den letzten tagen vor
weihnachten und ich finde heute sich
auch allgemeine schöne geschenkidee sind
nicht nur zu weihnachten
aber eben jetzt dieser besonders jetzt
zeige ich einfach mal was sie aktion
daten benötigt und zeigt euch wenn man
es da ein schichtet das glas hat ein
fassungsvermögen von 580 milliliter und
da passt dieses projekt richtig perfekt
drin und ich starte jetzt einfach direkt
auf der waage und lebte als 100 gramm
mehr rein
dann nimmt das kurz von der waage runter
und klopft ein paar mal auf die
tischoberfläche damit eben wieder schön
glatt wird dann kommt wieder drauf dann
gebe ich dann als jesus sei es mit dazu
und einen halben teelöffel backpulver
dann kommt der braunen zucker das sind
75 gramm
dann kommen 100 gramm weißer zucker rein
50 gramm gekauft
dann nochmal 50 größe
und dann kommt 25 gramm schokoraspeln
also mindestens 28 aus und je mehr rein
bekommt umso schokoladiger wird ist also
bei mir sind es jetzt 35 und es reicht
auch sonst ich denke nicht mehr so und
bei diesen weg gläsern kommt da jetzt
noch so ein gummi drauf da gucke ich
dass es am hinten ist also ich möchte
dass mein logo von das bag logo dann
kommt der deckel drauf
dann hat es hier so zwei clips mit denen
man das fest macht natürlich einen
rechts und eine links aber guckt dass
das gummi richtig drauf sitzt und das
war es dann schon also so sieht es dann
aus und es könnte natürlich aus
gestalten wie er das möchte
also ich habe es auch schon so gemacht
dass ich das mehl durch zwei geteilt
habe also dass ich praktisch zweimal 50
gramm hatte habe ich nämlich noch mal
weiße schicht zwischen aber ich finde es
auch so richtig schön
das könnte jetzt natürlich dekorieren
möchte jetzt hier oben ein herzchen
drauf mit der aufschrift zutaten viel
liebe nicht ganz los und hier habe ich
eben noch die anleitung also die
brownies dass man eben alle zutaten mit
90 km zerlassener butter und zwei eiern
verrührt und dann gibt man das ganze in
eine form die etwas zu 20 mal 20
zentimeter hat und baktus etwa 30
minuten bei 175 grad
die nicole i hat es zum beispiel so
gemacht hat er so ein kleines etikett
ganz süß finde ich echt cool mit so
einem paketband und hier oben hat sie
noch die aufschrift halt das finde ich
auch ganz deutlich und mit so einem
kleinen körbchen haben
das können da wirklich so machen wie ihr
euch das am besten gefällt
wie ihr seht habe ich jetzt in wenigen
minuten ein süßes kleines geschenk
gemacht was wirklich individuell
ist und von euch persönlich kommt ich
wollte jetzt eigentlich noch irgendwie
die blau dies dann aussehen wenn sie
fertig sind
allerdings hat ihm einen menschen
aufgefuttert und falls ihr unbedingt
wissen wollt wie die aussehen als ich
habe auch ein foto für euch gemacht dass
zeitgleich und wenn ihr wissen wollt wie
ich die zubereite sagen kann ich euch da
gerne noch ein kleines video dazu machen
aber wie gesagt die muss man einfach mit
90 grad seiner mutter und zwei familien
das wird dann so richtig klebriger teig
und dann kommt da am besten in säure
brownie backformen die hat bei mir so 20
auf 20 cm geht aber auch mit 25 25 auf
jeden fall sind so richtig klebrig süße
braune die aber nicht zu süßen ich habe
den zuckeranteil wirklich schon
reduziert die schmecken eigentlich so
wie die von mcdonald's als so richtig
schöne eben amerikanische brownies und
jetzt komme ich noch zu meinem zweiten
thema heute und zwar zu der schürze
viele von euch haben ja im august dieses
angebot von mir genutzt mit der
kitchenaid diät gericht gestellt habt
und da gab es ja eine schürze von mir
mit dazu und es war wirklich ein
leidiges thema muss echt sagen ja jetzt
schon dezember und ich habe die schützen
immer noch nicht weggeschickt gehabt und
zwar jetzt einfach daran
ich habe nicht damit gerechnet dass
wirklich so viele leute bei mir eine
kitchenette bestellen
ich habe zu meinem mann noch gesagt dass
heute vielleicht 20 das schaffe ich es
noch die schützen dann eben doch zu
bedrucken mit namen und so dass jeder
seine eigene individuelle scherze entern
erhält aber leider oder zum glück keine
ahnung für euer also für euch was glück
dass ihr eben das angebot noch genutzt
habt und die maschine gestellt habt für
mich war es beim leiter nur noch nicht
mehr so realisierbar dass ich euch die
schönsten eben selber druck und deswegen
habe ich eben nach einer alternative
gesucht nach der gute alternative ich
hätte euch da jetzt wirklich mit
schablone euch die namen aufgedruckt und
die des logos sowie ich eben machen
wollte aber weil
300 maschinen und 300 schiffen geht es
leider nicht mehr ich noch berufstätig
und mache ja die videos für euch jetzt
habe ich echt lange gesucht ich habe
nach schätzen gesucht nach dem aufdruck
nach dem logo und habe wirklich viele
schützen auf der hand gehabt aber ich
wollte ja auch dass die qualität stimmt
und dass ihr mir jetzt auch alles glaubt
was ich erzähle zeige ich euch einfach
mal was ich für schützen bekommen habe
und zwar war es so eine die ich gestellt
hatte eigentlich von der farbe und so
richtig süß so ein großer haben wir echt
gut gefallen
natürlich auch die marineblauen für die
männer aber wenn ich mir dann soll die
schütze anguckt da haben die da vorne
einfach so zum teilstück dran gemacht
und ich finde das sieht man heute sicher
direkt vorne wo man die schütze
praktisch sieht und die setzen da die
reststücke dran also anscheinend hat der
stoff nicht mehr gereicht und die haben
da diese stark ich irgendwie sauber
genäht da die enten franzen total aus
und das habe ich dann echt nicht ein
bisschen zu schiffen an euch zu schicken
weil ich selber mit der qualität eben
nicht zufrieden war das gleich immer mit
der blauen schürze daraus gelassen dass
die einfach danke oder stoff nicht
gereicht hat einfach kein stückl dran
genäht haben und es hat mich wirklich
viel zeit und viel kraft gekostet da
wirklich auch mal schiffen zu finden die
mir gefallen und die eben auch dann
bedruckt werden konnten
dann habe ich vor einem monat ungefähr
die bestätigung erhalten habe denen dann
eben dieses neue logo geschickt und dann
gingen die schätzen bestellung raus dann
habe ich gewartet und gewartet die
schüsse kamen immer noch nicht einmal
angerufen und da haben wir gesagt das
kannst du doch schon längst angenommen
dann habe ich dabei der post angerufen
damals am ende
dass irgendjemand aus unserem ort die
schützen angenommen habe ich kenne die
wir so nicht keine ahnung wurde schützen
genommen und sind dann gegen das ganze
eben wieder von vorne los wieder
schützen bestimmt wieder das logo
hinschicken
und jetzt haben wir endlich geschafft
ich jetzt einen cent das sind jetzt
diese hier
ich habe jetzt ein deutlich alle in
diesem marineblau und habe eben mein
neues logo drauf mit der aufschrift der
die torten welt.de
schade finde ich es jetzt eben nur dass
eure namen ähnliche individuellen
draufstehen aber wie gesagt ihr müsst
ihr leider entschuldigen weil es einfach
nicht mehr möglich war für jeden
einzelnen namen drauf zu treffen und
zwar ist einfach nicht mehr möglich für
jeden das individuell machen zu lassen
aber ich denke und ich hoffe dass euch
diese schätzen aufgefallen das was ich
an der auch ganz gut findet also meine
ich auch männer dabei habt ihr schutz
gestellt haben
das war musste ich mir diesen knoten
rein machen weil ich habe ein ziemlich
kurzen oberkörper und die schürze warum
wir etwas zu lang
aber die könnten exakten der entweder
feststecken oder knoten rein machen aber
bei den meisten dürfte eigentlich passen
also bei mir passt oder eben nicht weil
das ist ein bisschen zu lang aber meiner
meinung zum beispiel hat es gepasst und
die schützen da denn vorausgeschickt
also vielen dank noch mal an alle die
das bei mir bestellt haben alle die
natürlich bei dieser aktion nicht
bestellt haben haben keine schützen mit
der beiden wo ich diesen spritzgebäck
aufsetzen denn natürlich auch so toll
ist und die schützen werde jetzt auch im
shop anbieten da können das sie
bestellen
den link dazu setze ich euch unten in
die infobox und es werden jetzt auch mit
der zeit etwas andere designs kommen und
andere schriften mit etwas mehr auswahl
da freue ich mich schon drauf und
aufgrund der ganz nachfrage kam ich auf
die idee in den eigenen shop zu können
weil ich einfach dann erst gemerkt habe
dass die nachfrage wirklich da ist jetzt
möchte ich gar nicht weiter reden möchte
ich einfach noch mal ganz herzlich bei
allen mit
und ich hoffe dieses video gefällt euch
ich hoffe ein ort oder eine oder andere
macht die idee mit dem geschenke glas
macht mit dieser backmischung wir sehen
uns schon morgen wieder da hat nämlich
wieder jemand bei mir bestellt morgen
gibt es ein kleines weihnachtsmenü und
wenn euch interessiert werner mir
gestellt hat und was ich alles zauberin
dann schaltet machen wieder ein bisschen
[Musik]
neben doch das ding als die schüler
nämlich immer als kommissar abgerutscht
war
als probleme mit dem material ja ich
mich doch bin ich schon mal gucken ein
bisschen ding jetzt zu schaffen